[Music]
buckle up
we're going to take the orbit of this
rock and kick it into high gear
behold the moon breaking its planetary
speed limit
how would this event flood cities
what would happen to the Earth's crust
and why would the moon go Rogue
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon orbited Earth faster
the moon orbits around our Blue Marble
of a planet at a comfortable and
reliable speed of one kilometer per
second
and if that seems fast do you well hold
on you haven't seen anything yet
so how could this happen
if the moon kept getting closer to Earth
the gravitational pull from our planet
would increase
that would make the moon's orbits speed
up tremendously
That's the basis for Kepler's Third Law
so if the moon kept creeping toward
Earth it would orbit faster and faster
and if that happened
how would this event freeze the planet
every 27 days the moon completes a trip
around Earth well not anymore get ready
to see this Celestial body more often
and with the moon's increased visibility
and speed lunar eclipses would be a
regular sight
but that lovely view in the sky wouldn't
make up for the hell on Earth Below
if the moon moved closer the
gravitational pull would rip into the
Earth's crust
this increased force would create
earthquakes and increased volcanic
eruptions across the globe
and don't think you could cool off by
the ocean to escape the Heat
let me explain
the oceans ebb and flow thanks to the
moon's orbit the Earth's gravity and the
Sun
so as the moon inches closer the ocean
tides would become much larger
how large are we talking
they would be eight times higher than
average
coastal cities would flood and some
islands would become blanketed
underwater for most of the day
almost 700 million people living in
low-lying coastal areas would be in
constant danger if they weren't
evacuated
but what would happen if the Moon
started to move even faster well
remember Kepler's Third Law the moon
would only orbit faster if it got closer
now if it came within 18 470 kilometers
it would reach What's called the Roche
limit
that's the point where the Moon is so
close to Earth that the tidal forces
between us would get strong enough to
tear this gray rock apart
thankfully this wouldn't be able to
happen because as its speed increased
our moon would be launched into the
cosmos
yeah that's because once our natural
satellite reached 1.4 kilometers per
second it would have enough momentum to
escape Earth's gravity
as it fades from sight you might feel
relieved at first
after all the Earth's rotation would
slow down without the moon so days would
become longer
and finally you'd see an end to the
constant earthquakes and devastating
floods but in reality
this is where the real nightmare begins
the tides would become smaller and
weaker without the Moon
any Coastal ecosystems that weren't
already destroyed by the massive
flooding would now be completely upended
without churning Tides animals that
depend on food sources normally floating
in the ocean wouldn't get the nutrients
they need to live
and without the moon's light nocturnal
Predators would have difficulty
completing a successful hunt
this could create a mass extinction
event of creatures on land and at sea
and while life on Earth would be flipped
on its ear so would the planet
Earth has a tilt of about 23.5 degrees
this angle of its orbit makes the
seasons possible
but it's the moon's gravity that
stabilizes this tilt from going any
further so without it the seasons could
stop
weather patterns might hold in place
until the end of time
but if the Tilt increased well it could
cause extreme weather conditions and
once again the Earth could be plunged
into an ice age
yeah a faster lunar orbit could Fast
Track all life on Earth to Extinction
okay so instead of losing the moon what
if we crowded the sky with the moons of
Jupiter
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]